this is burna boy i'm with bleach report
and i'll be dissecting place of African
players here you hear you he baka big
man is just vicious man you know like
that forget it
anta - cool come on babe
obedience is better than sacrifice yeah
man the big tree fall baby it must be
because it's better than sacrifice
everyone has a struggle you know
especially when you have to go somewhere
else know you're home you know try to
make something happen
yeah if we develop on the floor I always
think about my dad and that motivates
man we pushed it to you know play harder
and something that's very respectable
another vulnerable than anyone who has
accomplished other things part you know
that's all that's basically what the
African giant as part of what it means
you know in idea what the watch mostly
is soccer football and just like the
Nationals that's what they called
blatant disrespect and if I was that
goalkeeper against have to fight my
forum for the game after a fight that
was disrespect man you see our guys
girls hanging in the air for a while the
ball was ending was still in the air now
we have to fight no no this no not this
this is disrespectful
why even fancy just removed the keeper
you have been evicted from the post hey
why you wanna do me like Rob ow you see
the head
this is rusty the visit to school go
like that
the leg the head felt like it was leg
the result ball went thing with the
speed if you evolve you if you kick the
ball don't go that fast that's what they
call the head of Drogba no sorry can't
blame the kid be good the goalkeeper
compliment
there's nobody that could have saved
that I'm Berlin boy and this was
dissected play